i think education's the most important
thing in the world i was getting bees
and apps all of high school but every
weekend in springfield new jersey i was
reading international wine cellar cover
to cover hundreds of hours of education
it just wasn't memorizing where saturn
was because that's what i was gonna do
for a living room and in 1974 you got
out of college that paper put you on
every company in america was like we
will hire you it's changing forget about
little old vaynermedia you have the
biggest companies in the world that
don't even ask for that but this debt
thing drives me crazy unbelievable
amounts of kids get out of school have
30 40 90 a hundred thousand dollars in
debt people are [ __ ] choked and then
they have to take jobs they don't like
we get the depression unhappiness ninety
percent of people aren't even doing what
they went to college for and now here
comes all the comments on social i know
if you're a lawyer and a doctor good go
to school for that you're right i don't
want a doctor who never went to school
working on me you're absolutely right
the problem is there's like six of those
things yeah what about everybody else